N.Learner B4: روان عادل إلى أخبار
N.Learner B4: سامعيني.
N.Learner B4: الحمد لله والله.
Learner B1: الحمد لله بخير.
N.Learner B4: يا رب دينك؟
N.Learner B4: كنت وصلكم طاسك وكري صح كده.
Learner B1: ، مظبوط.
N.Learner B4: شاي فون.
Learner B1: كان في حاجة مبارح لما طلبت يكتب كومنتل.
N.Learner B4: دخلونا جروب عالواتساب معاهم دايريكت بحيث تومات شورن يعني ما فيش.
Learner B1: مع ال إي أو مع بنيامين.
N.Learner B4: لأ ما أدمين. أنا آسفة مع البني آدمين فور دارك كوميونيكيشن فورجين كاسيز.
Learner B1: إمم.
N.Learner B4: دي حاجة حلوة جدا واستجابوا يعني لمشاكل الفترة.
Learner B1: بالضبط؟ ريف.
Mentor B: زي ما شباب عاملين إيه مساء الخير.
Learner B1: لأنه.
Mentor B: ازا هيك الاخبار والذين.
Learner B6: طبعا.
Mentor B: نعم.
Learner B6: مساء النور. ازيك يا باش مهندس.
Mentor B: الحمد لله.
Learner B6: كله بخير؟ الحمد لله.
N.Learner B4: مهندس.
Mentor B: مساء النور. ماذا تتكلم؟
N.Learner B4: الحمد لله والله انت عامل
Mentor B: الحمد لله.
N.Learner B4: يا رب.
Mentor B: يلا بنا نبتدي.
N.Learner B4: يلا عشان شايفة الموضوع كبير أوي في طسكي.
Mentor B: لا، أوكي ما كان تو ويكس فانتوا اتسحلتوا بقى صح ولا
N.Learner B4: كانت سهلة سهلة سهلة يعني.
Mentor B: ماشي حلو يعني جزء من حياته يعني عنده توقعات مختلفة.
N.Learner B4: إمم.
Mentor B: نعم، أحب الأول آخذ على اللي فات
Mentor B: ممكن نلف لفة كدا على كل 1 يتكلم في بتاعته بس نعدي كده شوية على يعني على باسكتس اللي انتو عملتوها وإيه
Mentor B: البوبلمن اللي اكتشفتوها ملي
Mentor B: و إيه يعني والخطوات بتاعت دوت وصلتوه لها ازاي وبعد كده نتكلم في الإسبنت الجديد؟ بقى اتفقنا
Mentor B: وممكن تشوف سكرين او حد كده مجهز جوا وزن فايلز نعمل كدا.
Mentor B: هيا بنا شباب مين يحب يبتدي
Mentor B: يا الله يا نادر بما انك شو 1 تكلم.
N.Learner B4: ماشي أبدأ طيب ال الأسبوعين في أسبوع 1 الصراحة كانت سوبر توف
N.Learner B4: هاو إيفر صحبت لحد كان ساعات في الأسبوع اللي فات دا كان عادل. عادل. اقترح فورم
N.Learner B4: وهو كريديت الفرن وكريت الكوستيانس يعني خلينا نقول تذكر هو السوبر هيرو فحتة هاو تو مانجر ثينكس
N.Learner B4: من ناحية فورماس وناحية نمشي عليها.
Mentor B: فرنش.
N.Learner B4: عندي فعلا مجهود كبير جدا في الحتة دي عشان بس نقاط ويسهل علينا.
Mentor B: لا لا والله نو الهدف بتاعة الناس الأخرى
Mentor B: التنين صفتينج أبريشن أوذر تشيفرز يعني دول صفقتين من فالله ينوع عليك انتو الاتنين.
N.Learner B4: شكرا شكرا يعني عندي صرح كان معانا في الحتة دي كان معنا حتى لما سلم الطاسكي كان بيسألنا عن مين إيه وصلتوا لفين كله كان ستريس الصراحة الأسبوع اللي فات وكله كان هو يكون موجود حتى هو تايه معانا بس كان موجود.
Mentor B: عبير العامل إبداع.
N.Learner B4: لا عمل شغل كبير جدا الأسبوع اللي فات.
Mentor B: الكلام ده عادل. أنت أوكي يلا بننكر.
N.Learner B4: لا، لا، خالص بالعكس يعني هو يستحق الصراحة فا
N.Learner B4: الأسبوع اللي فات كانت الطاسكي شوية كنا حابين نحنا ناخد من زميلنا مشاركين كنا شوية مقلقين من حتة إن هو ما حدش يرد أو ما إلى ذلك فأنا قلت أنا هنبعث
N.Learner B4: ونشوف بقى الرد حيمشي ازاي قعدت جاهز الأسئلة جهز كل حاجة وبدأنا بعتنا وصلنا 6 ردود
N.Learner B4: كان محتاجين وقت أكتر من كده عشان نقدر نجيب إينسايد و نبدأ نشتغل فعلا على بروجكت بس يعني
N.Learner B4: زي ما إنت قلت فده كان السمبل اللي عندنا وده اللي اشتغلنا عليه من دي.
Mentor B: مش طب أسألك سؤال.
N.Learner B4: أكيد طبعا.
Mentor B: دلوقتي يعني كم 1 منكوا عدى التمن ساعات
Mentor B: ده أول سؤال السؤال التاني عايزيني أمشي وزن أشوف بتاعتكوا ده ون واي ان احنا ون واي اننا اسمع أسئلتكو وأسمع الجود والبدو تحبوه
Mentor B: فأنتو شايفين تحبوا تنفذوها أوه.
N.Learner B4: نخون.
Mentor B: السؤال الأول اللي قضى الأسبوع اللي فات
Mentor B: متوسط في الأسبوع أكتر من 40 ساعة.
N.Learner B4: 40 ساعة.
Mentor B: مش.
N.Learner B4: ما تشربين.
Mentor B: ولا 1 ساعة 30 ساعة بصراحة هي بينك وبين ربنا كده بصراحة 30 ساعة 20 ساعة تسلم.
N.Learner B4: داعش.
Learner B1: لو بتدوها ممكن لو بتوها ممكن.
Mentor B: كل ساعة معدل 4 ساعات في اليوم صح
Mentor B: كده معدل حوالي 4 ساعات في اليوم
Mentor B: أوكي وزينب 40 ساعة 20 ساعة قصدي ماشي وعادل انت ساكت خالص 5 ساعات ولا
Learner B1: لا، لا، لا، والله شكرا لك. محدش فيهم في المكسر ومحدش فينا كان مكاثر يعني كلنا كنا بنسعى و
Learner B1: ودخلنا ميدي مع بعض وضبطنا مع بعض يعني شكرا كلنا عملنا كده يعني بصراحة ما فيش حاجة.
Mentor B: ال ماشي بس 20 ساعة.
Learner B1: أم.
Mentor B: ماشي.
Learner B1: بالتوها يعني مش عارفين نعمل طب القسط طب الأسئلة محدش بيرد في التهم اللي فيها و20 ساعة وحلوة أوي.
Mentor B: ماشي وبص هو الانتنشال ديزاينز إن هي تكون ثمن ساعات في اليوم حلو
Mentor B: الأسبوعين اللي فاتوا الي هو يعني الأسبوع اللي فات قصدي اللي هو دخل في اسبوعين كان ديزاين ان انتو تقدموا في اليوم 10 ساعات
Mentor B: حلو يعني ده جانب حلو الجانب الجانب الآخر
Mentor B: وات إف إن إنتو استغليتوا بقية الساعات اللي هو كان حيفرق كثير وجزء من مشاعر التطه كانت حتقل كثيرا انا عارف ان هو في منكو بعضو شغال فممكن يكون ايتس نوت
Mentor B: إن هو فايد العشر ساعات دولت
Mentor B: بس يعني هي عشان هي فاهمين هي كإنها فول تايم فهو الموضوع. كان ديزاينز على كده أصلا
Mentor B: المعلومة دي في في تايمز يعني انتو يو نو واوكيشن المحدد عشان بس ما تحسوش بس ان هو
Mentor B: نوتواليت تايم تمام متفقين لأن إنتو كبود منجز يعني
Mentor B: إكسبكتو ده على فكرة يعني إكسبكتوال هو انت اليوم بتاعك من 8 9 ساعات انت قاعد كده يعني الا لو انت شغال في الشركة هادية شوية يعني بس ده جانب من وده يعني طبعا كل ما تاخد في الحاجة تحسن كلما تحسن بتاعك
Mentor B: السؤال التاني تحبوا أمشي في الأول بوت أوت كامبز بتاعتكو 1 1 ولا
Mentor B: تبدوا تسألوا وتقولينا اللي كان واقف قدامكو أون ديسكاس أون ديسكاس من تحبوا ال ميتين يمشي ازاي
Mentor B: طب اللي عايز أوبشن الأولاني اللي هو نمشي في الأوت بوتس ون باي ون أو يعمل لايك او يعمل اي حاجة.
Learner B1: أنا عندي لو ممكن حضرتك تعتبر نفسك مكان وبتحل يعني مطلوب منك تتصرف ازاي من.
Mentor B: دي سهلة رسالة يعني يعني هنقول ده هنقول ده كده كده بس إنتو تحبوا يمشوا زي لأني أنا يعني
Mentor B: في ون واي إن أنا هدي يعني ون واي لحد حنمشي في أول بوت ون باي ون دا حيخلي نركز على التفاصيل شوية بس بعدكو عادي حياخد اللي حيبدأخذوا ون باي ون كده غطينا كل البوينت
Mentor B: الثاني
Mentor B: أول أوبشن التاني ان احنا نتكلم لو إنتو عندكوا أسئلة عامة يعني انتو خلاص حاسين عايزين نتكلم شوية فنتكلم في أسئلة وكدا وحجاوب بينهم كدا كدا سؤالك عادي عندهم طواوي أنا لو مكانك حفكر ازاي في التاسكت دي ماشي
Mentor B: فتحبوا ون يرفع إيده عايز أوبشن تو بوتينج هيخلص خلال 10 ثواني
Mentor B: ده الصمت ده شباب انتو مش مختارين ليه.
N.Learner B4: أنا.
Learner B6: هو.
Mentor B: إيه.
Learner B6: أوبشنتو.
Mentor B: مش ندى.
N.Learner B4: أوبشنتوفر.
Mentor B: من ابعتي لو مش حضرتك تكلمت
Mentor B: زينبتوا إنتو إنت خلاص إنتو كده كسبتوا ماشي حلو شكلها مش عارفة تختطأ
Learner B1: كمان.
Mentor B: ماشي طيب يلا بينا ماشي 1 يقول لي الأسئلة بتاعته ماشي
Mentor B: إتفضل إتفضل عادل يلا بينا إبتدي بالأسئلة بتاعتك.
Learner B1: ما عنديش أسئلة بس ممكن أقول الحاجات يعني عنيت فيها شوية مثلا كأسئلة
Learner B1: مثلا السؤال اللي أنا سألته برضه هو فكرة التوست برينت فرنش
Learner B1: كنت حتقدر إزاي تجيب داتا دي موجودة صح فرنش
Learner B1: القرار أو الحل اللي انت اجيتو له ان هو فعلا ده الحل المناسب لنا.
Mentor B: عندك وخلينا نبص هو الموبايل ون يعني خلينا نمشي ون الموبايل ون أحسن بالنسبة لأن أنت بتسأل عن خليني أمشي معك في ون باي ون.
Learner B1: هو.
Mentor B: ما.
Learner B1: بفتكر الأسئلة.
Mentor B: أنا أنا كنت بس عايز أمشي هون باي ون عشان يعني أمشي باي تيسكا عندك عشان تشوف أنا بفكر إزاي لأن إنت محتاج يعني محتاج ديتيلد شوية
Mentor B: بس ميلي يعني إنت إنت بتذكر دلوقتي هو ال تذكر بسيطة. أنت بسيط عندك عواصها عندك صح؟ ولا غلط
Mentor B: كل كل الطاسكيست تدور حولين هذا بتاعك
Mentor B: قلي البهوب المائية عملت يوزع وعملت ماركت عملت كده صح؟ ولا غلط.
Learner B1: مظبوط.
Mentor B: مزبوط. أنا لو مكانك. أنا دلوقتي إنتو إنتو قلتوا نزلكم شغالين عليه دلوقتي، صح ولا غلط.
Learner B1: صح.
Mentor B: ماشي
Mentor B: فأنا دلوقتي أنا أنا أعتبر نفسي محظوظ ليه لأن أنا نيوز أصلا حوالي ندى وياسر وزينب كلهم أصلا وبابا في البرج كلها إيه أصلا بروجكت اللي أنا أشتغل عليه دوت اللي أنا محتاجه فأنا محتاج أشوف إيه مشاكله مشاكله وأشتغل عليه
Mentor B: فأول أول نقطة أول نقطة كنت حستغلها أنا كنت يعني خليني أمشي معاك الفل أول حاجة أنا ال ساينز الحاجة دي أنا محتاج بقى أفهم ال فيشين بتاعة معمول ليه وإيه الناس اللي في الموقت اللي بيقبضوا بنفس الطريقة وبيبثوا إزايوشنز اللي عملوها
Mentor B: عشان أقدر بتاعتي حلو الكلام فأنا من هذه النقطة. ننطلق من هذه النقطة لا، أنا هكتشف إن دي بيزنس الناس عايزة تعمل
Mentor B: طريقة جديدة للتعليم هكذا فأنا لو عرفت المنبت اللي عنده شفت الناس الموجودين في الموكيت أنا عندي دلوقتي
Mentor B: دي نقطة مهمة إندست ثري إيه على إنداستري ماشية إزاي عشان أقدر حتى لما أجيب أشوف نفسي بلوشن ولا ولا ويد أوشن إنتو حد عارف ويد أوشن ستراتيجي
Mentor B: أوكي بشدة والكتاب بيتكلم عن هو بيقولك باختصار، إن أي أي بيزنسيس بتتنافس
Mentor B: بتتنافس في محيط حلو يا إما المحيط جاي من لون الدماء ليه لأن هو في في حروب طاحنة فهي جدا بشكلها المباشر. فا ما فيش حد ميز نفسه بحاجة لأ ده كلهم هم يعني تقريبا بنفس الموديل وبخبطوا في بعض بقى بيقللوا أسعارهم معرفش إيه والكاتب كان لأ
Mentor B: يعني ده مش مفضل إن إنت أبيض فيه لأن ده بيطلع تقوى واط وفي نفس الوقت بيأذي ال بيزنس بتاعتك في والحاجات دي وفي ولازم إن إنت تبقى هاف إكسلانت
Mentor B: إكسلانت كل حاجة يعني كل بوسيس فيها واخد الفول مارك
Mentor B: عشان تعرف في هذا في هذه في هذا قصدي في ودي الناس تقولك طلعت بقى أسماك قرش من اليد ويشن ده إحنا نشوف محيط جديد إحنا نخلق فيلم وفي منافسين كثير يعني أمثلة كثيرة على ناس عملت يعني مثلا أبل لما عملت الآيبود مثلا
Mentor B: لما برده قبل برضه لما عملت تقابل ايفون يعني في الأول عندنا مثلا تاني اواني مثلا مشروب فواكه وسط مشروبات غازية كثيرة حتلاقي في في أمثلة كثيرة على ناس بتكاوي هي بتنافس في نفس ال ماركت جديد
Mentor B: هي مميزة فيه حلو الكلام و فده أنا ليه كنت بتطوق في الموضوع ده عشان بتطوق إن إنتو تفهموا كومبيتيشن كومبيتيشن.
Mentor B: فهمها مهم جدا لأن أنت تقدر تو بوزيشن يو سلف يعني إيه ال كومبيتيشن ده فين لأن إنت
Mentor B: يعني إيه مثلا أنا دي منافسينها ديل ويموت ويموت بس ناس بمليارات الدولارات وإحنا لسه بنبتدي، فهو طبعا مش طبيعي إن أنا أخش حت ليهم وأقول أصل هعمل زيهم مش طبيعي خالص فلازم أنا أخلي الناس تجيلي مختلفة عنهم
Mentor B: حلو فهي دي الفكرة،
Mentor B: فأنت فهمت وفهمت فين فهمت كل حاجة عشان قلت عليها دي ننتقل للمرحلة الجاية إن أنا عايز أفهم البوتكس بتاعي فأنا أفهم لفة في وأنا ممكن أستعين أسأل عن بروجكت مانجر وأنا مثلا أنا لو مكانك في الإنترنشال كان بروجكت نفسه
Mentor B: ستايل شغال ازاي يعني عملتوا اللي ما عملتوش المشاكل بتقابلكم كل هذه أسئلة. أنا محتاج اجاوب عليها
Mentor B: وأفهم مثلا على مثالنا ال إنجين يعني مثال أو أنا فيها يعني فكنت هجيب حد بقى من من المصممين بتاعها وأبدأ أتكلم معاه محتاجة أفهم اليوزرز بتاعها
Mentor B: طب أنا كده أنا كده لحد دلوقتي أنا عمال بجمع أنبت عشان أفهم أنا إيه
Mentor B: الدنيا ماشية فين فهفهم طب إيه سوف رأيكم في انتنشن شايفين إيه مشاكلها شايفينها تطلعلكم مشاكل كثيرة
Mentor B: ليست يعني إن إنتو محتاجين تحلوها حلو ده حيؤدي لي صديق ده حيؤدي إن أنا فاهم المشكله
Mentor B: بمعظم أبعادها فجي هقولك يا عادل أنا عايز أو تميز وأعلي ريفينوز مثلا أو عايز أعلي إنجمنت أو عايز أوتومات فيها فأنت تقولي إحنا عندنا نتمايز فيهم مثلا 1 تنين تلاتة،
Mentor B: فأنا لما أجي أقولك إن مثلا أنا عايزة أعلي ويفنيوز نمسك هذا أوبجيكتيف فنعلي ويفنيوز. طيب عشان نعليها فإحنا محتاجين ناس تو جراين أكتر ده مثال لو إحنا نركز على بوزيشن أو محتاجين
Mentor B: نأفصل عن الناس اللي موجودة أو محتاجين أو يعني نعمل حاجة تاني يعني في عندي كذا أوبشن
Mentor B: فأنا بقى من فهم دوت هقول ده أفضل أوبشن دلوقتي 1 2 3 عشان أنا شايف يوزرز ذكروا كلهم 1 2 3 فاهم أنا فهمي للماضي أدى أدى إزاي إن أنا أقدر أضيف المشكلة وأقدر أحدد ال سريعا،
Mentor B: فهنا بدأت أنا أحدد يعني أنابجيكتيف قدرت أحدد ال بروبليم وقديت أحدد ال سيوشن اللي أنا حشتغل عليه
Mentor B: وأنطلق منه بقى خلاص طب السيوشن طب معلش مثلا جيسي أوه بيقولي أصل إحنا عايزين نعمل فيتشر الفلانية مثلا
Mentor B: مثلا في هاي ووترز مثلا هدجبلكم مثلا على
Mentor B: هذه خطوه ممكن ان تكون منطقيه زمان ليه لان احنا وي هاف يعني خلينا نستكل بهذه الطريقه
Mentor B: فتقدر تقدم إجابات استراتيجي حتى
Mentor B: مش أي فتشي وخلاص مش هتقولك مثلا إحنا عندنا مشكلة فتقول طب هل هو الحل أصلا. لو انت فهمت مشكلة يوزر
Mentor B: وفهمت مشكله، فأنت لازم تتكلم مع الناس انت ممكن تحل المشكلة خليني هزلكم مثال أنا عديتون في واحدة من كنت حتى لسه ضارب المثال ده الصبح للشباب عشان كدا مثال جي
Mentor B: واحدة من الحاجات الغريبة جدا إن كان في مترك وهو فري تو بيض الفري تو بيض
Mentor B: ده ان انت بتحول الناس اللي خدت لفيديوس
Mentor B: حلو طبعا مهم جدا لأن إنت إيه ده اللي بتزود بيه عدد أكتيڤ سوبسكرايبر والكيمتروك عندنا كان في سبيستون إحنا محتاجين نزود الاكتيف سوبس كويس
Mentor B: ده لقيته كام
Mentor B: 97 في المية أو 96 في المية حوالي رقم زي كده طبعا رقم خزعبلالي يعني عدد الناس اللي بتاخد معظم الناس يعني حوالي 96 في المية يعني معظم الناس اللي بتاخد ده كاسب جميع البنك في
Mentor B: فهو حاجة حلوة طبعا و والتفكير الأول إحنا عندنا وعندنا لا حد يقاومها لدرجة إن كل الناس بتحول
Mentor B: وطبعا شكل هو يعني أكيد في إن وراء هذا الرقم طبعا مع صح ولا غلط يعني لو اديتها البوينس الصح والغلط لقيتها صح؟ يعني كل ديتها أكيوت
Mentor B: بدأت أتكلم مع يوزر وبدأت أبص أكثر في الفلوس وتشك الفيديو كودنغ الناس بتستخدم أبليكيشن والكلام دوة لقيتلك حاجة خطيرة بقى حاجة خطيرة إيه
Mentor B: إن معظم الناس اللي خدت ال فايتوا هي أصلا كانت ناوية عندها تسوبس كويس فأنا
Mentor B: كأنه 1 ساب واخد القرار سواء ألد أو نيو قولتله خذ سوبسكريبشن فهو قاللي ماشي حلو فطبيعي إن هو بعد الشهر حيكمل سوبسكبشن يعني أنا ما عندوش مشكلة هو أصلا ناوي ينتقل سوبسكرايب ليه لأن إحنا وي بوسيشن حطينا
Mentor B: في المكان الغلط فلما بدأنا نروح نصلح دوت
Mentor B: ونحطها في المكان الصح للناس اللي هم أصلا قلقانين اللي هو خد فكرة فقلقانين إن هم ياخدوا لا واحنا حطينها لهم المتر ده بدا يقل وصل تقريبا 70 في المية بس عدد بدأ يزيد
Mentor B: ثيس بقى إيه يعني ثيس أند إكزامبل يعني على إن إنت إزاي ممكن تكون مشكلة ما تبسطلهاش بتاعها ما فهمتش مشاكل، فهو دائما حتى لو السيوشن واضح قدامك
Mentor B: روح انظر وتكلم مع الناس هذا مهم جدا.
Mentor B: مش عارف جاوبت سؤالك عادل ولا لأ.
Learner B1: مهم جدا. تمام جدا. وأنا كنت المفروض أشكك في المشكلة المكتوبة في الطازج.
Mentor B: هو ممكن يشكك في المشكلة عادي يعني مشكلة محتاج تبص تلبس كاب تلبس كاب بتاع ان هو اصلا هي دي مشكلة ولا لأ يا جماعة ما إحنا نبص بقى
Mentor B: محتاج تشكك. ومعظم الذين سيفكر معظم تشكك في اكثر ف
Learner B1: المشكلة مش في.
Mentor B: إيش.
Learner B1: في المشكلة مش في السيري يوسف.
Mentor B: لا.
Learner B1: يا سيدي.
Mentor B: بعد كده يعني هو انت الناس في الشركة.
Learner B1: تمام.
Mentor B: ماشي.
Learner B1: شكرا.
Mentor B: شكرا على الدول بس فإنت إيه خليك زي ما بقلك هو هو يعني هو بيوحي كابيت ويتعلم بنفسه،
Mentor B: فأنت شوف إنت حتتعلم إزاي وإبدأ كيف الوية تتعلم بيها تواصل مع الناس خليك أوبن ما تخافش من حاجة يعني ما تبص مثلا وهم حاطينلي الطريق كده وهم عايزينها بالشكل كده لأ يا باشا انتقد
Mentor B: واسأل انحطت بهذه الطريقة ولي أنت وليه لازم نعملها بهذا الشكل وكده كده أنا بالنسبة لي المهم إن أنا حاجات بتساعدكو بس أنا مهم إن إنت عرفت ديسكوفر وعرفت طلع ال
Mentor B: ماشي.
Learner B1: تمام ماشي الحال.
Mentor B: اتفقنا عليه ماشي مين بعتقد مستحيل.
Learner B6: معلش إحنا لسه في مرحلة الرسالة ولا.
Mentor B: كل 1 هنعد عليه يسأل أسئلته ولو في وقت بقى نمشي في الأول بتصل على.
Learner B6: تمام حلو قوي. أنا عندي سؤال انا دلوقتي. انا كنت بذاكر ما كورس كدا يفيدني وكان كلم طبعا كان بتكلم على حتة الفانيل
Learner B6: انا لما بحثت عن الموضوع ده يعني ده أكثر حاجة بتميز فأنا برضه يعني حاولت إني أفهم وأشوف مثال عليه فكدا حد بيتكلم الفاينل ده اللي بيكون
Learner B6: يعني مثلا في طلبات في فانيل درايفر. وفي فانيل لليوزر مشتركين في بروسيس.
Mentor B: حلو.
Learner B6: فيعني أنا برضه ما فهمتش أنا يعني ده حددها إزاي وحتفيدني بإيه ويعني أو لأ
Learner B6: لنا هو قال كلمة فانيل وانا انا ما فهمتش فانيل انت عايزاه.
Mentor B: هو فونل
Mentor B: دي وحدة من الحاجات يمكن أنا سقطتها كمان في البوسيس إن إنت اسبيشال لو البوتكس فيه متريكس بس انت عشان ما فيهاش فأنا ما ذكرتهاش
Mentor B: هديك إكزامبل برضو من ال ال اللي أنا عشتها في حياتي في موضوع الفونيل ده وحدة من يعني مبسوط إني اشتغلت عليها
Mentor B: انا كنت شغال او باي بس شركة كدا لها كان ليها فيجن طموحه يعني ان هي تهبط المجال الطبي كله ببعضه يعني
Mentor B: فالمهم إن إني كنت أنا بمانج. هل ستاج الاساسي بتاعهم بيقدم ديسكاونت بيديكال و أوبشن تو ديجيتاليز ميديكال ويكروز بتاعتك فأنت والشيتات. والحاجات دي ما تتهميش تبقى موجودة ديجيتال عشان الحاجات دي مهمة جدا في التشخيص وانه يعني مهم اهميه لو تعلمون عظيمة يعني انت حاولت تحافظ يعني نصيحة بأول
Mentor B: تحاول ان تحافظ عليها دائما يعني
Mentor B: لأن الناس ممكن تتنبأ منه بأشياء كثيرة اسبيشالي بتاعنا فالمهم إن المهم إن إحنا يعني زي على قالولي ان احنا عايزين نعلي ريفينوز
Mentor B: فأنا من احد الخطوات اللي عملتها اننا طب هاتلي بقى الفانيل بتاعت البودكت والفاينل بتاعت البودكت المحببة. إلى قلبي متركس حلو فاينل بيوتكس دي بتقولك يا باشا انت فيس بتاعت البودكت
Mentor B: بتختلف الترتيب بتاعها بس هي ما بتطلعش عن حد عارفهم
Mentor B: الناس تفتح المايك وتتفاعل.
Learner B6: غريب.
Mentor B: إيه.
Learner B6: دي حاجة مثلا زي الأر واي كده.
N.Learner B4: ما شاء الله.
Mentor B: لك.
N.Learner B4: جملة تاني معلش تاني سؤال.
Mentor B: السؤال حد عارف البايك ميتلكس.
N.Learner B4: لا.
Mentor B: ماشي دي مهمة جدا. تعرفوها إحنا بنخرج بس المعلومات دي مهمة جدا انتو تعرفوها
Mentor B: دي بقى بتقيس إيه هو بيقولك عبارة عن سيكس ستاديجز ماشي فايف في بعض الأقاويل بس سيكس دول خليني أشمل برودكت بتاعك إنت جبت ال يوزر ولا لأ على برودكت بتاعك أكتيڤيشن استخدم برودكت بتاعك ولا لأ
Mentor B: بعد أكتيڤيشن وتنشن قعد على بعد ما استخدمه. قعد استخدمه تاني ولا يفنيوز عرفت تولد منه حد تاني ماوس عشان الشخص الجاي الجديد ده يتحسب فين
Mentor B: في فتبقى هيكل عمالة تغذي بعض ودي اسمها يعني اللي هو مشغل نفسه انت كده بقيت ليد دي
Mentor B: دي أكتر شيكات بتعمل أطباق يعني فيسبوك ما أعرفش إيه كل الناس برودكليت دول هما ناس برودكت بتاعهم أصلا هو يعني هم مش عايزين يعينوا
Mentor B: بي دي تيم وسيلز تيم عشان يبقى لهم تيم ولا محتاجين نشوف إعلانات ولا حاجة ده هو جدا بيبيع نفسه حلو الكلام فده المثالية اللي إحنا محتاجين نوصلها إسمها بي إل جي أو برودك. جوس
Mentor B: اكتبوا الاسم اللي عايزين تبحثوا عنه أكثر
Mentor B: طب ال ال أنا لما جبت بقى نرجع للمسلم كنت بقوله دي أنا بستخدمها دي فانيل عامة بتاعتك
Mentor B: حطها وبص عديتها وشوف عندك عاملة ازاي فأنا مثال على مثلا أنا أول ما حطيتها لقيت شيء خطير جدا. شيء قاتل الشيء القاتل دوت ياسر
Mentor B: يعني طبعا كلها كان فيها مشاكل متلتلة بس أول مرحلة اللي هي اللي هي إحنا تعريفنا طبعا تعرفنا تعريف الموحد بيختلف على حسب إنت معروف كل مرحلة إيه بالنسبة
Mentor B: فإحنا كانت عندنا كانت ساينب لقيت 50 في المية من الناس اللي بتدخل بس وده غريب جدا لأن هو بتاع ساينب 90 في المية.
Mentor B: فأنا لما لما لقينا كده لأ إحنا محتاجين نبحث أكثر المشكلة لقينا بقى إيه 50 يعني خليني بس أقولك المشكلة طبعا وأنا بقولك عندي مشاكل من سلسلة ثانية طب إنت ليه رحت لمشكلة
Mentor B: هنا بقى فكرة بقى استخدام لو إنت بيوتايزويسون دي أكتر ناس أكثر الناس بتجيلها
Mentor B: فأنت يعني أنا بقولك الباب بيدخل 1 بس أنا حخلي الباب يدخل 2
Mentor B: تخيل تأثير الباب اللي دخل 2 على بقية جوا. أنا مش حعمل أي حاجة
Mentor B: جاست الناس اللي بتشترك حتتضعف بس ليه لأن دخلت تنين فالإحتماليات هي هي يعني اللي هو 5 في المية هيبقى فاليد على التنين بس كان بدل ما كان 5 في المية على الأقل على المية فيجبلي 5 بقى 5 في المية على المتين. بقى يجبلي 10
Mentor B: فأنا ضعيفت ال يفنس بتاعتي من غير أي حاجة فأنت شفت إزاي أنت هنا ال طبعا لازم تستخدمه مهم جدا
Mentor B: فلو قلنا خلاص إحنا حنستغل هنشتغل على الساينب على ساينب والسايناب طبعا إحنا كنا مع شركة اسمها اس ام اس مصر كانت بتأخر ال مسيج وبتدخل في كيوب كده وكانت المسج بتوصل بتاعت الأوتوب متأخرة للناس
Mentor B: فكان يحصل في باك اند فالمهم القصة كلها دي
Mentor B: وهذا الدرس التانيينغ تين من الأول.
Mentor B: أنا كنت عامل كده فكنت بكلم 1 من الإنجنيوز عن نحن مع اسم مصر واحنا مندفعلهم فلوس يعني كتير يعني عشان نستخدم بتاعت فاير بيز الفاير بيز أوت بي اللي هي كانت زمان فري يعني
Mentor B: و وعملها تيست من اللي معانا وكدا وحطينا وعملنا وصل كام بعد ما عملنا الكلام ده
Mentor B: وصل 90 في المية الود بتاعه الطبيعي 90 في المية إحنا تقريبا حوالي إيه ضعفنا الناس اللي داخلة بحوالي ون بوينت إيت
Mentor B: فأنت عدد ال يفنيوز عندنا تقريبا إضعفت بسبب هذا الأبديت اللي قعده ون ويك
Mentor B: فده مثال على إزاي إن إنت تبص لل فاينلز إنت دائما لازم تخلي الفاينلز بتاعة أي برودكت قدامك بصص على انت يعني احنا مش حيكفي بس أشرحلكم عشان هو موضوع طويل، فممكن أوتكلز أبعتلكم أوتكل لو عايزين نتكلم عنها
Mentor B: إزاي المراحل دي المرحلة دي إن إنت تكون بس على الفميل بتاعتك المشكلة ودي ودي عادل برضه من الحاجات اللي إنت لازم تبص عليها لو البوتكس ده ببوفايد ببوفايد الديتا.
N.Learner B4: يا ريت؟ قدر يعني.
Mentor B: ماشي فكريني بس يا ندى لو أنا نسيت معلش عشان.
N.Learner B4: ماشي حاضر.
Mentor B: أوكي جاوبت على سؤالك ياسم.
Learner B6: فرنش.
Mentor B: ماشي تسلم ماشي مين عنده سؤال تاني.
N.Learner B4: والله أنا من إجابتين.
Mentor B: سبعينات.
N.Learner B4: كومبري هينسب جدا يعني الصراحة غطى على كل الأسئلة عندنا تحديدا.
Mentor B: حلوه حلوه أمانة ماشي زينب؟ أنا مش سامع صوتك خالص مش شايف الا موضة بتاعت
Mentor B: لا هو الصوت كويس عندكم شباب ندى زينب بتسأل بس صح.
Learner B1: السوق. كويس المشكلة من عندك.
Mentor B: ماشي مش عارفة زينب لو انتي المايك عندك شغالة اعتذرت تقريبا عن المايك صح ولو عندك أي أسئلة قوليلي
Mentor B: أو اكتبيلي فرشات
Mentor B: عايز أسألك ماشي حلو خلينا ماشي شكرا شكرا لا إيه إتفضلي يا سعود.
Learner B6: عندي سؤال ثاني.
Mentor B: تفضل أكيد.
Learner B6: أنا يعني من كلامي مع حضرتك تتكلم بالأرقام ودي حاجة بصراحة فإزاي إكتسب المهارة دي. إننا
Learner B6: كل كل حاجة معينة أو هل إنت درست مثلا حاجة لها علاقة ولا ده حاجة طبيعية يعني أنا شايف الموضوع.
Mentor B: حقولك بص إنت كبودك المانجرز هتبقى ليك بيرفنسيس كبودك مانجر هتبقى في الأشياء لأن أصلا هتلاقي في تصنيفات مانجر مانجر يعني إنت ليك بيرفنسيس في الأرقام حلو خليني أقولك
Mentor B: أنا يعني أهم مشكلة يعني قصدي أهم من أهم الصفات في هو لغة يا ريت تتكلم وأنا مش حقولك إن إنت مطلوب منك إن إنت تتكلم بلغة الداتا بس يعني انت مش مش كلامك المفروض يبقى في أوكامب بس لا انت محتاج للناس اللي حواليك اصلا بتتكلم لغة داتا
Mentor B: وأنا قابلت ده مشكلة مثلا في في شركة من الشركات اشتغلت فيها الناس ما تتكلمش بديتها
Mentor B: فإنت أصلا محتاج تبني الوعي ده يعني أنت أصلا. هيكون حتكون مطالب إننا تخلي الناس تدور أكشن دوت أصلا إن هي بلاش بقى نبدأ كلام إعتباطي وحاسس ومش حاسس ونفسي ومش نفسي وأعتقد وما أعتقدش الكلام ده
Mentor B: نبطلوا خالص فأنت محتاج إيه عشان هتسمع الكلام ده كثير
Mentor B: يعني فأنت هتلاقي حتقعد في جلسات كده مع اسبيشالي معز حيقلك أصل أنا حاسس البتاعة ديت معرفش لو جبناها إي تمام طبعا الله يكون في عونك هو ما عندكش ده يعني أحد المواقف اللي بتحط فيها بتبقى أصعب موقف في حياتي يعني ما بتقدرش تواجه نفسي دي
Mentor B: عشان إنت مش حتقدر تتكلم مع حد ليفل أعلى منك بديته
Mentor B: يعني هو ده سؤال حيسألك في إنترفيوز إزاي تهند كولدز ملي تتكلم
Mentor B: اللغة غديتها 1 إثنين 3 إحنا ماشيين 1 إثنين 3 إزاي بقى تكتسب المهارة دي
Mentor B: إن إنت تقوى يعني تعود نفسك يعني دي ماينست تكتسبها بإن إنت
Mentor B: لو انت دائما قادر تنتقد أي كلمة بتقولها
Mentor B: يعني انت بتجي على نفسك في اي كلمة بتقولها فأنت مع الوقت هتتكلم بالحاجات
Mentor B: حلو دي دي نظرة فلسفية للأمر
Mentor B: تجيبها إزاي بقى تجيبها بأن أنت تقوى كتب عن تفكر قبل ما تجاوب
Mentor B: ماشي دول طرقتين في طرق كثيرة أخرى يعني بس دول الحاجتين يعني اللي أنا بفكر يعني اللي أنا استخدمتهم يعني مني عشان أكون صريح برضه لأن هو الموضوع يعني بيعتمد برضه إنت جاي منين أنا كنت أنا كنت تخصص باي فيزيكس في الكلية
Mentor B: وكنت بحب الستيستيكس جدا ويعني ومرتب على حتى على كليتي كنت بفارق كبير عن اللي بعدي في مدار الستكس ده فإيه، فأنا أصلا جاي من من هزيل أنا بقولك ليه الموضوع ده لأن ممكن يكون عشان بس إيه
Mentor B: في بعض الناس بيتخلقوا بإيه أو بتبقى الظروف بتهيأ لهم ميزات كده بيخدوها فاهم قصدي فأنا من أحد برضه الحاجات اللي ربنا قاومني بها. كانت الميزة. دي إننا جاي من من مكانة، وأنا كنت أصلا بدرس ساينس
Mentor B: فيزيكس وحاجات إحنا ما فيش هناك خالص هي كلها إيه قوانين ومعادلاتها اللي محتاجة إثبات فأنا مش جاي فاهم فيمكنة عندي دي برضه
Mentor B: بس هي بتتبني عادي باللي قلت لك كده أشرح لك
Mentor B: طيب ماشي الكتاب يا زينب لو في عندك سؤال أشرحلك كتاب ون أوف يعني أفضل الكتب اللي هو اتعمل في الديتا إسمه لين ديتا لين ديتا أناليتيكس تقريبا هو لين ديت حاجة مش فاكر بالظبط
Mentor B: الكتاب ده رائع جدا صراحة ياسر حياخدك كده في فلو وهيب بتقدوس وتفهم بسبكتيف كل شيء
Mentor B: وفكر قبل ما تتكلم إبحث قبل ما تتكلم دا موضوع برضه مهم إن إنت لما تكون فاهم كويس ببعض وقوي زي
Mentor B: فاكرين كنت بقول لكم يعني خلصتوا ساعات ما تقعدوش كده يعني إنتو خلصتوا التذكرة هي مش فكرة التذكرة وخلاص ما فكرة وإفهم هيبقى عندك ديت
Mentor B: حتنفذ أي دي فهمت الناس اللي بتعمل حواليك ساعتها تقدر تتكلم فاهم قصدي
Mentor B: فمش عارفة جاوبت على سؤالك ولا لأ.
Learner B6: أعزائي الفل زي الفل جزاك الله كل خير.
Mentor B: لين ديتا الكتاب اللي اسمه لين فرنش.
Learner B6: في.
Mentor B: طبع سلسلة لين لو حد عارف سلسلة لين اللي هي لين لين برودكت والحاجات دي كلها.
N.Learner B4: اللي هي بدت باللين.
Mentor B: هي بالضبط لينس أب.
Mentor B: أنا ما قرأت كل الكتب بتاعت شايف ما عجبنيش وأنا ماشي في الأول كده حسيت إنه هو ليفل مبتدئ كده شوية
Mentor B: أه عشان قويت كتب شبه يعني فحسيت إن المعلومة خدها قبل كده
Mentor B: يعني يعني ردا لو لو جالك كلين استوتب أو كتاب ثاني مثلا ممكن يبقى
Mentor B: كونتيجيز مثلا مش في نفس المجال بس كنتيجس تعرفي.
N.Learner B4: لا ما عرضتش الصراحة. أنا كنت في الكلية ده تبقى دي البداية.
Mentor B: ماشية هو حلوة كبداية ده كتاب برضه أشرحهولكم جدا بيتكلم عن الزيت الكبيد فيول أي حاجة فير إزاي يعني ليه الحاجات هو بيجاوب على السؤال دوت
Mentor B: ماشي فهو بيتكلم بقى بيقولك كم قزمة وده مهم جدا عشان برودكت بتاعك يبقى برودكليت.
N.Learner B4: اللي هو كونتشيز واي ثينجز كاتش.
Mentor B: سوري.
N.Learner B4: اسمي ثينجز كاتش.
Mentor B: هو.
N.Learner B4: أوكي.
Mentor B: ماشي أي سؤال ثاني يا شباب زينب كاتب طويل الجزء اللي هبطني في التاسك إن بقى إن بعد السي في
Mentor B: لقيت إن ما فيش مشكلة عند يوزر ما فيش حد فقد حماس المشكلة عند المنتوز بس
Mentor B: وكمان مدة ال فيدباك كانت كويسة عادي اللي فات بس هو اللي طول 8 ساعات وكمان ما كنش متاح عن متدربين من السي في والفيد من مؤسسات أخرى المشكلة المعودة مش موجودة زي ما طلع كده
Mentor B: سواء ده إنتو عملتوه يعني.
Learner B6: هو إحنا عملنا سرفي نسأل فيه الطلبة يعني المشاكل عندكم بالنسبة في.
Mentor B: بال الأسئلة حلوه حلوه. نحن ندخل في مواضيع حلوه إزاي
Mentor B: بس أنا أصلا الشباب كانت حصل وكان في مشاكل شفتوا حضرتوا.
N.Learner B4: بتاع
Mentor B: يعني المشاكل اللي فيها ده في حد من اللي قابلوكوستغلوا حيجي معاكوا وعمل حل لنفس المشكلة من دوت
Mentor B: اسمها مارين.
N.Learner B4: اسمه اسمه.
Mentor B: إما ما ينقص ده.
N.Learner B4: إحنا حضرنا 1 بس مش عارفة.
Learner B1: كان يوم ما كانش في غيره هو اللي كان يوم الاثنين.
Learner B1: عمرك اسيدي غير.
Mentor B: طب خذوا سكرين شوت بودو وشفتوا المشاكل.
Learner B1: بشكل.
Mentor B: ا.
Learner B1: ما هو المشاكل بقى اللي كانت مختلفة جدا عن المشكلة أم.
Mentor B: المشكلة في التذكرة. عندك.
Learner B1: بالظبط. أنا المشكلة عندي وبرضه انا لما كعادي بالأول تمام.
Mentor B: ماشي.
Learner B1: المشكلة بتقول إن الناس متأخر فهم بيمشوا عايزين يعني حماسهم بيقل و
Learner B1: ويفكروا ما يكملوش ده المشكلة باختصار يعني كمان
Learner B1: حاستها ان هو لا مش للدرجة. دي تمام.
Mentor B: أيوه صح؟ صح؟
Learner B1: أم باهي.
Mentor B: صح؟ صح المشكلة دي مشكلة واحدة بس فأنتو إنت ممكن تطلع بواها أنا مش عارف بس هو ليه المنتوج أو إحنا لسنا منواجه مشاكل في
Mentor B: خليني بس أقولك أبص على حاجة لحظة معليش الشباب وانا معاكم.
Learner B1: لا حول الأسئلة حد.
Mentor B: شباب حرجع بسلمه ولا عشان أتفاجئ بإيه بحاجات غريبة بتوصلكوا ساعات.
Learner B1: يا ندام ممكن أنا.
N.Learner B4: فلم برضه.
N.Learner B4: صح.
Mentor B: لا أنا شفت سأقولكم سأقولك الآن
Mentor B: لا هي مش دي المشكلة اللي أنا كنت بعتها
Mentor B: يعني هي المشكلة اللي أنا كنت بعتها كانت بتتكلم عن إننا محتاجين ال فور بيك واس فورس برينس نيك
Mentor B: ماشي هو هو غالبا الناس فهمت المشكلة. غلط فهم بعثوه غلط
Mentor B: والذم على هذه الحتة بقى معلش
Mentor B: بس هي المشكلة المشكلة يعني زي ما انتو وصيتوا هي مش مشكلة فيدباك بس أنت محتاج برضه إيه
Mentor B: تطلع البتاع بركز على كل من هنا وواضح يعني إنت دلوقتي بص كل المشاكل طلعتوها دي فاليت خلاص يمشوا فيها مش لازمة لمشكلة فيدباك ماشي.
Learner B1: هو دلوقتي كان الكلام في إنه هو في مشكلة في يعني.
Mentor B: تفضلي يا نجحة.
Mentor B: لا، لا أنت قلت حاجة.
N.Learner B4: الصدفة مش عارف كان في حد بيتكلم ولا لأ كنت بقول لو تبعت لنا المشكلة اللي حضرتك كنت عايز تبعتها إن المشكلة جت لنا من إن إحنا عندنا مشكلة في إن الفيد باك
N.Learner B4: بيطول مشتركين عليه.
Mentor B: هي هي المشكلة باختصار ذي فاينز سكوب أند سبسيف كير ماشي
Mentor B: خليني أقولك أنا المشكلة بالنسبة لي إن أنا عايز أو
Mentor B: إنتو إنتو بتوعوا فإحنا عايزين أفكار إزاي نقدر أنا أعدلهم المشكلة اللي اتبعتت دي بس إيه النقطة اللي أنا عايزها منكو
Mentor B: اتفقنا؟
Mentor B: فأنتو إفتحوا سكيل يعني أنا حقول حتى قبلوكو سكو إشتغلت على مشكلة فيدباك نو بوبليم ما فيش خلاص فيدباك بتأخر معاش إيه بس
Mentor B: يعني نقطه بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم يعني.
Learner B1: تكون مشكلة بس مش مشكلة.
Mentor B: يعني نقطة الفيد باك هي مشكلة بس مش مشكلة كبيرة صح؟ عادل وفي نفس الوقت مانجر محتاج يطلع برا اللي بتقله يعني
Mentor B: فهمت يعني حاولوا تعملوا كده عشان يعني تضووا تاخدوا يعني عارفين إن الحظ بيتك مش مش بيجي
Mentor B: بس فهيدي نقطة، من النوم لأن إنتو حتى بتاعكو لو إنتو مشيتوا بس اللي هو إنتو عايزين تحلوا 1 2 3 ما أخدتوش إينيشتيفز عميقة
Mentor B: ده يعني حيخليكو عاديين مع الوقت لكن لو إنتو بقيتوا ده هيطولكو جدا وح يخليكوا يعني إيه أبريشيتد في المكان اللي إنتو فيه
Mentor B: ماشي.
Learner B1: أنا كان لي كل بالضبط السكوب كبير وكل حاجة بس الفكرة إن لو سكوب كبير
Learner B1: أنا حبقى. محتاج داتا وناس يعني حتى لما فكرت أسأل الإيه هو.
Mentor B: مهو إنت الدفع موجودة موجودة عادي. أنت أي حد تتقاسم معاه من كده عندك اليوسس يعني قصدي.
Learner B1: في.
Mentor B: لكن.
Learner B1: أو أي حد من المسؤول في هو اللي ينزل فورم على أساس يكون إن معظم الناس أو أغلب الناس فتحوها وعملوا أما هي لما نزلت الستة بس هم اللي عملوا.
Mentor B: فهمتك بس هي يعني خليني أقولك على حاجة
Mentor B: يعني أنا حراجع معاكس عشان دي انا عندي تاني في الحتة دي اول اسم رباعي مسارك سنك دراستك أو شغلك أو فيدباك يوصلك. بعد أدي من الوقت
Mentor B: إمتى بعتت الطسك خذ وقت طويل الفيدباك مثل صديق
Mentor B: يعني آي لايك كيد إن إنتو عملتوا أول حاجة إنتو جامدين جدا
Mentor B: ماشي يعني ده شغل عادي انتو تحوقتوا من غير اي حاجة لكن لكن
Mentor B: وانت بتتكلم مع اليوزر لازم تبقى حريص جدا لأن هو يوزر يبقى أي حاجة بالنسبة له. تمام يعني هو مش محتاج هو بيبقى إنسان مش عايز يحرك أصلا يعني أنا دخلت مع يوسف كثير
Mentor B: إنت لو مش قادر تطلع منه كلمة
Mentor B: قادر تقوضوا لأن إنت في الجزء ده تشتغل كأنك مخابرات. فهمت؟ أنت مش أنا مش فاهم انترفيو عشان
Mentor B: يقول لي إن البودكت بتاعي حلو أنا مش عايز كده وده مش هيفرق معايا أنا عايز تقولي المشاكل الموجودة في البودكت بتاعي
Mentor B: فنقطة مهمة جدا وهي نقطة إن إنتو
Mentor B: الأسئلة ضيقت جدا لدرجة إن هو إيه يعني في الفوم
Mentor B: وايضا اقولك على حاجة هي الفوم انا عارف طبيعتها ما تخدش غير الأسئلة دي بس هي مش حتديكوا سايتس هي هيوز دي انت بتصين فيها مشكلة ولا لأ
Mentor B: ومش داتا ولاية بول قوي لإن إنت يعني باختصار
Mentor B: اللي يضمن إن هو يقول إن عندي مشكلة أو ما عنديش مشكلة يعني اللي يضمن إنه صحة صحة الديسيشن بتاعه
Mentor B: انت لازم تسأل الأسئلة مش بدايوك تو يعني لأ لازم تتعلم الأسئلة الثعبانية
Mentor B: اللي هو مثلا أو فيدباك بيوصلك بعد أدي من وقت التسليم حلو دا سؤال دراجتي جدا
Mentor B: ممكن بقى إحنا إنت لو عايز مثلا كتاب مونتست يقولك السؤال ده يتسأل إزاي في آخر مرة في آخر مرة فيدباك دي وصلتلك بعد قد
Mentor B: طب بعد لما هو جواب السؤال ده طب إنت شايف إن ده وقت طويل ولا لأ حلم
Mentor B: وهنا يعني أنا أنا غلطت غلطة هي المفروض تبقى أوبن إنتي كوشن مش المفروض مثلا تقول له يس أو نوم يعني طب إنتقلوا طب إيه رأيك طول في مدة الوقت ومدة الوضخ يبقى أنا كده أوبن إنتي كوتش أنا أخليه يقول اللي عنده
Learner B1: وبين الناس يعني برضه إحنا.
Mentor B: عشت النار.
Learner B1: الستة اللي.
Mentor B: أيوه.
Learner B1: أنا قابلها.
Mentor B: لا بس هو على فكرة مش بهذا السوق السرفي لأن هو إنت لو مديله كوصة هيكتب قليل عادي برضه يعني قصدي عادي جدا دي حاجة يعني أنت مثلا لو في في فوم حتلاقي الناس انت كاتبلهم مش حعمل على عدد الكراكتر عشان كده خلاص دي مش مش الناس مش حيبقى عندها مانع
Mentor B: فاهم قصدي
Mentor B: بس أنا متفهم برضه أنا بقولكوا أنا أنا ما بحبش أستخدم موضوع الفيد باك فورم ده أنا والفوم وألفوم زي ما بحبهاش يعني بحبها في ناس بتستخدمها بس هي أنا شايفها جدا الناس في ومعرفش فكنت أفضل
Mentor B: يعني اعملوا مع الناس تحجزلكوا وتتكلم مع 1 تنين تلاتة طب إنت شايف دي أحسن إزاي أو دي أحسن إزاي.
Learner B1: ما.
Mentor B: بس.
Learner B1: برضه معلش لو كل الناس جايين يعني أنا مثلا ما كنش عندي مشكلة يوم يومين عادي تمام
Learner B1: فكنت عايز أعرف هو فعلا فين فين الناس اللي قالوا إحنا عندنا دي مشكلة عايزينها تنحل
Learner B1: عشان كده هدفي الأول إن أنا أعرف عملت ال فورم وعملت.
Mentor B: لا هو مبسوط منه يعني مبسوط من مبسوط معجب معجب بالطريقة دي لأن هي الطريقة دي أثبتت إنه ما فيش مشكلة في الفيد باك صح إنت بتقولي كده.
Learner B1: دي مشكلة بس مش.
Mentor B: ، ماشي.
Learner B1: يعني كان من ضمن التحدي من الستة كان أنا مش مستريح أتعامل مع بشكل كبير ده أنا حاسة بالملل
Learner B1: يعني سابوا حتة خالص سابوا حتة اللي هو فيدباك والباسك وكل حاجة وراحوا لحتة.
Mentor B: طب مسألك سؤال.
Learner B1: أنت.
Mentor B: أسألك سؤال ما تيجي ناخد خطوة كلنا أنا مقتنع بالكلام اللي انت بتقوله وإنت صح تماما يعني أنا مقتنع بالكلام اللي انت بتقوله تماما وده كلام جامد دي ماين سيبت رائعة.
Mentor B: تعالوا ناخد الموضوع فرنسا وتعالوا نعمل فورم ثاني فبرأيك كيف
Mentor B: انت عندك توأمب دلوقتي سبكتيف اللي حصل الناس علقت
Mentor B: وانت فيدباك فو بنبعت فيدباك. حلو مش الناس طلعت ديساين أو سيغنال إن هو في في حاجة تاني
Mentor B: ودعلى الداتل اللي تطلع ديت
Mentor B: لو عايزين صبوط مني عادي ما صبوطكو خلي الناس تبعتها ويست يعني حاجة كده الناس كلها تملحها.
Learner B1: بالزبط.
Mentor B: ما عنديش مشكلة نعمل كده عادي أنا خليلك الناس اللي تعمل كده بس إحنا عايزين بقى
Mentor B: أسئلة تتعمل بقى بطريقة يعني تسأل السؤال إيه رأيك في مثلا طب إيه مشاكلك طب شايف ليه دي مشاكلك
Mentor B: طب إيه شايف التحسينات اللي نعملها طب إستفدت إيه وناخد ال وناخد فيدباك وناخد الفيد باك فوم ده حلو أوبشن تاني ممكن نسأل على فيدباك بتاعة اللي فاتت لإن هي حصلت فالناس ممكن تكون عملت فوم وما رديتها نسأل الناس اللي هم اللي عملوا كده
Mentor B: إحنا عندنا ليستوا في مشاكل حلو إنتو طلعتوا لستوا في مشاكل مختلفة عن ديت.
Learner B1: كنت محدد يعني المشكلة هي فينباك بتاعهم يعني على حسب التذكرة فيدباك بيجي متأخر ودي مشكلة
Learner B1: ما كانتش أوسع من ذي يعني مشاكل تانية.
Mentor B: ماشي حد فينكو شباب شاف مشاكل تانية.
N.Learner B4: لا، هي دي هي كلنا وكلنا.
Mentor B: إيش.
N.Learner B4: عندي أكسيس بتاعتها فده كان حد علق على أنا شفت مشكلة فيدباك
N.Learner B4: يعني ببساطة من خلال الإجابات هي بس فكرة كلها إن إحنا
N.Learner B4: ما كانش محطوط إكسبيكتاشن إن هو جماعة أو مايو هاف ديس مشكلة فيدباك هتكون إنحلت خلاص هو بس فكرة إن هو تريندم فده اللي كان عامله مشكلة.
Mentor B: أوكي حلو.
Learner B1: يعني ممكن مثلا يقولها صححها خلال الوقت ده وخلاص.
Mentor B: بالضبط.
N.Learner B4: هو تركمان بسيط.
Mentor B: جامد لا كلام جامد أنا أنا إنتو، إنتو دي الوقت لقيتوا وعملتولها بحث إنتو إنتو كده يعني لا تخفى بحثوا في النهاية وقلتولي أصل دي تتحلس ده كلام واع وإضافة كلام طيب تعالوا نتكلم.
N.Learner B4: وال أفيراج شتاين سبونس.
Mentor B: ماشي تعالوا نحل مشكلة ثانية. تعالوا، هنعمل الفورم التانية دي ونشوف بقى المشاكل كلها كل 1 منكو نقصينه يعني بعد ما ننقي المشاكل يختار مشكلة يحلها ونعملها بوتو طيب انت كده كده الأسبوع ده بتاع الأسبوع البوتو طيب
Mentor B: ألو السلام.
N.Learner B4: ال.
Mentor B: ماشي يغيروا ويغيروا من عندي فانتوا أنا أونلاين هولين مع الشباب كده إنتو عايزين تعملوا وتبعتوا فوم الفورم ده تعملهولي وانا حبص على الأسئلة وأديكوا في إيباك اعملوه وابعتهولي تعملوا سرعة عشان نبدأ نستغل الأسبوع ده
Mentor B: المشاكل بعد كده علينا مشاكل المشاكل ديتقسم ما بينكو و الأسبوع ده تعملوها بنفسكو على حلوها
Mentor B: يعني اشتغلوا عليها يعني خدوا المشكلة بقى انتوا نشتغل عليها كبوتو طيب عشان تطلعوها حلو الكلام.
N.Learner B4: عظيم جدا.
Learner B1: إمم.
Mentor B: ا.
N.Learner B4: دارفور.
Learner B6: من.
Mentor B: تفضلي عادي.
Learner B1: لا أنا بقول تمام جدا.
Mentor B: ماشي ماشي شكرا.
Learner B6: نعملها على.
Mentor B: معلش زينب بس بعتت حاجات وأنا ما شفتهاش يا جماعة ممكن أعرف إيه كان في أسئلة معروضة في حاجة
Mentor B: هو كان يوم الاتنين، فممكن تطلعيني معاهم الزناب او معرفش حصل ايمتى.
N.Learner B4: أنا عموما. ال ريكورد بتاع اليوم ده أنا محتاجة أرجع أسمع تاني فيد بتاع زمايني التراكس التانية عشان بس يبقى عندي شوية
N.Learner B4: باك إنفورميشن لما أحط الأسئلة بقى أنا عندي شوية قبل ما نحط الأسئلة
N.Learner B4: فلوتي حبعتلك على طول حبعته كمان في الغروبين.
Mentor B: ماشي ما كانش عنده مشكلة، فإحنا كنا معتبرين نفسنا يوزر ايوا كنا ينزل كبست بس مش عايز يستجيب
Mentor B: هم ينزلوا كبوست إلا ينزلوا كبوست.
Learner B1: الفور الفوم.
Mentor B: سيستم ماشي.
Learner B1: ماشي ماشي شكرا.
Mentor B: تنزلنا ده في اي حتة بس.
Learner B1: تربوية.
Learner B1: لو كان يعني كل الناس عارفة إن هو.
Mentor B: أنا خليه ينزلهم خلاص انتو محتاجين حاجة ينزل توتال كده أنا عيوني ماشي إعملوا بس تعرفون النهارده
Mentor B: أو بكرة عشان ما تضغطوش مزبوط.
Learner B1: شكرا.
Mentor B: بكرا.
Learner B1: تمام.
Mentor B: وحددوا الأسئلة بس الأسئلة وطبعا الأسئلة ماشي وأنا أخلي الشباب ومهمة عشان تكوس
Mentor B: ولحد دلوقتي إنتو أصلا شايفين مشاكل بعينكو في كل كل 1 ممكن بقى لو حتى مش محتاجين تستنوا فوق ممكن الواحد يبكي مشاكل كده المشاكل الأساسية اللي شافها ويبدأ يفردته يشتغل عليها لو في حد عنده حاجة حابب يشتغل عليها.
Learner B1: ممكن يكون في مشكلة.
Mentor B: أيوة.
Learner B1: يكون غيري.
Mentor B: لا، أنا بقولك لو هو عنده مشكلة لو حد عنده بقى مشكلة جاهزة
Mentor B: ولا
Learner B1: برضه للناس يعني.
Mentor B: هنعمل الفوم خلاص بقوله حد عنده دوت.
Learner B1: أوكي.
Mentor B: حد عنده أوبشن داي ديسكاس في مشاكل عادي يبدأ يشتغل عليها عادي متوقفش يعني على فوق.
Learner B1: أمين.
Mentor B: أوكي النقطه التانيه اكلمكوا فيها عشان المتينغ ما اطولش عليكم كانت اللي هو ده شيء مهم جدا والناس دلوقتي مش بس تبوتوا طيب
Mentor B: فأنا
Mentor B: أتوقع منكم تعملوا حاجة جامدة بلافوبول دوت أو أيا كانت التول تعملوا وتتعلموا تستخدموها إزاي خلي ده أوبجيكتيف بتاع الاسبوع تعلموا وتستخدموه الطول ازاي
Mentor B: وتستخدموها تطلعوا محترم نبص عليه بوتو طيب وتحسنو عليه عشان
Mentor B: تخيلوا اللي ممكن يعني إنتو ممكن اصلا ويك فلو لو حد حابب الوك فلو بتاع بيشوف النقاط اللي فيها بعد لما ان شاء الله الفورم يجي بالمشاكل يعني وتعملولها تصور جديد كز برودكت
Mentor B: هل.
N.Learner B4: وورك فلودي معك بش مهندس ولا مع مين نطلبها.
Mentor B: اسمو مع أحمد يوسف ونور.
N.Learner B4: أوف.
Mentor B: يعني فأنتوا ممكن تستخدموا إنتو تعملوا حتى إيه تبقى عاملة إزايداكت
Mentor B: لأن هي دلوقتي فلو ده بالكوميكيت واللي أنا بقوله ده ممكن يكون مشكلة ومش مشكلة إحنا مش محتاجين توكفلو فأنتو أنا بسلملكوا الدنيا إنتو اليدرز فيها يعني
Mentor B: بس مهم جدا انتو تكونوا تطلعوا عارفين تستخدموا سكيلز بتاعت اللافابول ديت مهم جدا بشيل بشيل مش بيخلي ولا سوفت وير إنجيني ولا حاجة
Mentor B: وده هدفي الساعة أكثر وأهم حاجة في في تعلموها يعني تعلموا كده وما توقفوش ويتفرجوا على فيديو بالذات طلعوا بيست أو من طلعوا حاجة شكلها حلو وشكلها جميل وفجيع للناس ماشي.
N.Learner B4: زي.
Mentor B: زي.
N.Learner B4: جدا.
Mentor B: كرما ماشي طيب عندكوا اي اسئلة تانية شباب.
N.Learner B4: أنا بالنسبة لي كل.
Mentor B: ماشي مفاجأة اللي جاية بقى.
N.Learner B4: ماشي يلا أوكي.
Mentor B: أوكي عشان وما حدش حضر وما حدش كده أنا اللي جايبها ان شاء الله.
N.Learner B4: إن شاء الله خلاص إن شاء الله.
Mentor B: أوكي
Mentor B: ماشي شكرا شباب وشكرا لمديرتكم العظيمة، وأنا مبسوط بال فليكسيبيليتي وبسرعة التعلم ومن باب صحن انتو انتقدتوا مشكلة وقلتوا إن هي مش موجود ده
Mentor B: الله ينور عليكن عايش عيش عايش.
N.Learner B4: ناخد كلنا.
Mentor B: نعم.
Learner B1: أنا معك.
N.Learner B4: مسيطرين.
Mentor B: اعتقد تعتقد يا ندى.
N.Learner B4: نأخذ كلنا.
Mentor B: أوكي ماشي أوكي يعني ححاول أكون حويص على كده طبعا الشركة مش هتكفي في الأماكن يعني حت إمم.
N.Learner B4: نقسمها شهور عادي جدا.
Mentor B: تبدعيلي يا ندى الفكرة. طب أنا هسألك سؤال.
Mentor B: ما
Mentor B: أسألك سؤال ما مدى تعلمكوا لحد دلوقتي في ال في الجرني يعني هل طبعا في حاجات عارف مش مش قوي لكن توتال بقى
Mentor B: الجاني بتاعت التعلم عاملة ازاي يعني شايفين في سريعة اللي ممكن يتحسن وتعلمتو لأ عشان ده الشيء الأهم بالنسبة لي يعني
Mentor B: عشان دي أمانة يعني هي الواحد يحاسب عليها قدام ربنا فا
Mentor B: أدخلي عدل أدخلي عدلي يلا.
Learner B1: يعني الاستفادة يعني أنا بكون مستفيد فعلا واحنا بنتناقش كل.
Learner B1: تمام المعلومات اللي حضرتك بتقولها ده أحسن بكتير أحسن من إي آي على فكرة.
Mentor B: ربنا يخليك.
Learner B1: نفيد بيك.
Mentor B: أوف.
Learner B1: هو.
Mentor B: ما تتوقعش إن هو البشرة.
Mentor B: على.
Learner B1: غبي.
Mentor B: 10 باصات.
Learner B1: مع.
Mentor B: هو يعني هو إيه حيبدلنا في خلال كم سنة هو عنده يفتح محل محل حاجة بقى يعني يبيع مثلا أداء سواميك يبيع.
Learner B1: مش للدرجة. دي. تمام يعني هو لو ينفع كان الكمبيوتر هو اللي عمل كل حاجة لوحده بس هو محتاج حد يستخدم الكمبيوتر.
Learner B1: شكرا.
Mentor B: هو الليفل الليفل يعني أنا جوا وأنا عارف الليفل الليفل اللي جاي موعد جدا يعني.
Learner B1: مرعب، وكل حاجة بس مش.
Learner B1: تخلي.
Mentor B: والله يعني بوينت أوف فيوز بس هو لو يعني ما بعتقدش إن هو حيوصل لليفل بتاع ال بتاع الإنسان عامة لأن من الخالق لكن لكن هو يعني موعب في تنفيذ الأشياء أنا أعتقد إن هو حيبقى قادر ينفذ أشياء كثيرة جدا
Mentor B: مشان عارف.
N.Learner B4: يمكن يعني هو هو عدد الناس اللي بتشتغل في كل مصري بشكل أجريسيف.
Mentor B: أيوا.
N.Learner B4: يعني لو في شركة عايزة مية موظف ممكن تدير شركة كلها ب 5 بس ده حيخلي الخمسة دول
N.Learner B4: ال ال هم حيبقوا في بوزيشن عالية جدا. هم عالية جدا بس القساط ده إنت محتاج تجري إزاي ما الأي آر بي جي.
Mentor B: طبعا طبعا الموضوع ده بنتكلم فيه في خلينا ماشي يعني انت المشاكل العادي اللي بتقابلها.
Learner B1: المشاكل
Learner B1: فكرة يعني أنا لو مثلا يخدمني أو يساعدني يوجهني صح؟ في التاسك دي يقول لي مثلا كفكرة يعني فكرة حتة التشكيك في الطاسك نفسها
Learner B1: اللي هو مش نقطة مشكلة كبيرة قوي هو ما يقدرش يقول لا انت نفذ وصلت مين عملت إيه.
Mentor B: صح.
Learner B1: تمام نقطة أكبر.
Mentor B: أيوا أنا دي نقطة قلتها للشباب بس هم يخلصوها يعني قلتلهم ما يشتغلش وكده لازم يبقى عنده حتى كونتيكس في المنتو اللي هو موجود في الجروب لأنه هو يعني أفضل أوبشن إن هو يكون بيسمع كلام المينتو ده وبياخده عشان يقدر يجيب بعد كده منه
Mentor B: والمنتو نفسو يكون مديلو مان سيت يعني كاتبله مانست اللي هو حيفكر بيها واللي هو هيمنتو ليكوا بيها بس هو الشباب لسه يعني بينفذوا في البودكت
Mentor B: فإن شاء الله تكون موجودة بس أنا أتفق معاك يعني في أصلا قايلها من 3 أسابيع، ولا حاجة.
Learner B1: منذ.
N.Learner B4: ممكن أضيف العادل يعني المشاكل اللي أنا مش ابعدل إنت خلصوا طيب عشان يبقى عشان.
Learner B1: كميلي براحتك.
N.Learner B4: مبدئيا بالزبط هو عايش مع نفسه لوحده فده بيخلد وهو مش معانا في اللي إحنا بنقوله.
Mentor B: يعني إنتو إنتو مشاكلكوا إنتو شايفين خلينا نقول بروجكت مثلا أو إنتو في ليرنينغ ليرنينغ بتحصل بس هي هو اللي صح.
N.Learner B4: بالزبط هو إي آي هو مش معمول في دينك. وبالتالي لو أنا عندي بص هو من أمريكا كتعلم علشان أجاوبك. على السؤال الأولاني أنا بتعلم شكل كبير وبشكل تحفة
N.Learner B4: وده اللي خلانا نقولو بوست أوف سايت بتاع حتة التوهان نيغاتيف سايد إن أنا أقدر لو أنا عندي بس جايدنس
N.Learner B4: اقدر اننا اطلع الرسوم دي تنكس
N.Learner B4: ليه أنا عارف أنا مش إزاي أنا بالزبط عامل شبه الشخص
N.Learner B4: ومشي بيتحدد الطريق ووصلت هاو إفر، إن أنا لو عندي عندي نور في الطريق.
N.Learner B4: أنا حقدر أوصل الطريق ده في زمن أقلت
N.Learner B4: او اطلع نتائج او اروح لطريق ابعد في نفس الوقت.
Mentor B: فهمتك يعني ماشي الحال.
N.Learner B4: بس كل إحنا يعني دي النقطة برضه كنت كلمتك عليها إحنا كيكة بنقع مع بعض كدا كدا كلنا بنفكر هاو إيفر إحنا محدش فينا عنده نونيت
N.Learner B4: فبيبقى محتاجين إن أنا أسأل شوية أسئلة في وسط السبرينت وفي الرتو ببقى. أنا محتاج أقولها أنا حليت صح ولا غلط أنا مش صح ولا غلط.
Mentor B: طب انا اقول لكم حاجة حلوة في الحتة دي يعني خلونا الفاينل لي بس عشان ما نكسر الفلوق
Mentor B: فأي حاجة بتوصلوني تتواصلوا بيا فيها برضه حتى لو أنا كده مش حقدر يعني مش هقدر الكواليس الأخرى اللي عندي في بس هي ممكن تجي لما خلاص حاجة خلاص إتفقتوا إن إنتو مختلفين
Mentor B: حد يبعتلي يعني حد يبعتلي يقولي في 1 تنين تلاتة 4 ده شايفين 1 اتنين كده فأنا وأنا أزبطكو في الحتة دي ماشي.
N.Learner B4: ماشي خلاص أنا ما فيش مشكلة. أنا هجمع من الشباب وهبعتلك بوفيه أي.
Mentor B: والله ماشي.
N.Learner B4: أوكي.
Mentor B: هي زي ما ابتلعتش بالي ماشي اوكي لو عندك حاجة كتبيها لو ما عندكش وقليلي.
Learner B1: معلش يعني مشاكل برضه اللي بيواجهها بيعرف يعمل وما بيعرفش الحاجات دي
Learner B1: ممكن برضه يبقى سيربي مخصوص لل أوي منترك.
Mentor B: لأ ما هو في بقى مشاكل بقى ممكن تطلع أصلي يعني يعني ممكن نعمل ده على فكرة يعني إنتو السيريك تاني طلعلكوا مشاكل كل 1 يمسك مشكلة ونقسم الناس ونبعث سيرفيه تاني عادي جدا
Mentor B: ماشي.
Learner B1: الموضوع. ده ونبعتلك.
Mentor B: بس إنتو ليه مش تعرفوا تشتغلوا عليه فهو يعني ونشوف الإكسبيرنس كل شي.
Learner B1: تمام.
Mentor B: أوكي
Mentor B: لا ماشي يا شباب متشكر جدا ليكوا شباب كلكم ان شاء الله متأكدة هتكونوا جامدين أنا شايف دوت يعني وشايف موجود عظيم فشكرا شكرا جدا. جدا. ربنا يوفقكوا
Mentor B: وموفقين ان شاء الله و آسفين برضه على بيته. اللي فت عشان عدم النظام في الموضوع.
N.Learner B4: شكرا ليك جدا ومش مهندس. شكرا على
N.Learner B4: ميتينغ النهاردة الحقيقة بشكل غير طبيعي.
Mentor B: شكرا شكرا شباب.
Learner B1: من عطنك.
Mentor B: الشوكولاتة يلا مع السلامة.
Mentor B: إنجوي باي باي.